There are some people who would get tired
of being placed in charge of SCP-914, or The
Clockworks.
The monotony of it all might make most of
us go mad.
The same routine, day after day, placing an
infinite number of objects into the Intake
Booth of the machine,
selecting one of the modes, be it Rough, Coarse,
1:1, Fine, or Very Fine,
and seeing just what sort of transformation
takes place.
But there was one employee of the SCP Foundation
who liked that routine just fine.
Dr. Gears was happy with his position, the
simplicity of the routine, the predictability
of it all.
He liked when the days stacked neatly together
in a row of uneventful stretches of time.
It was why he ate the exact same meal for
lunch every day: a plain turkey sandwich on
white bread, a cup of water, and a single
banana.
Of course, there was some variety in the events
that came about when testing the Clockworks.
There was that incident with Dr. Curtis, and
the pound of bacon placed inside the machine
alongside a photograph of SCP-682.
It had resulted in a miniature replica of
SCP-682, made entirely out of bacon, capable
of movement, and extremely hostile.
Though its size prevented it from doing any
damage, it did still attempt to kill any staff
it could find.
It had smelled mouthwatering,
but Dr. Gears had suspended Dr. Curtis from
testing with SCP-914 for the trouble,
and a day of having bacon grease cleaned off
of every surface in the vicinity.
There was also the incident that occured when
Dr. Hertz, in an attempt to score some free
music production,
placed a CD of his own original guitar songs
into the machine on the setting "Very Fine."
Rather than improving the production quality
of the tracks on the CD, the machine produced
a completely silent CD,
as well as a collection of books on songwriting,
singing, and playing the guitar for beginners.
Dr. Gears had to physically drag Dr. Hertz
from the room when, upset by the blow to his
ego, he attempted to attack the machine.
And of course, there had been the highly destructive
"Super Bouncy Ball" incident, which resulted
in 45 casualties and staggering damage to
the facility, as well as the aforementioned
ball
which was currently thought to be somewhere
in space, most likely orbiting Mars.
But for the most part, it was always the same
thing:
an object went in, a setting was selected,
and the object came out in a new, modified
state.
Wash, rinse, repeat, just like it said on
the back of the bottle of the brand of unscented
shampoo Dr. Gears had been using for the past
thirty years.
That was how he liked it, and as he sat at
his desk,
going over the test logs and preparing to
supervise another round of tests,
he turned on some of his favorite tunes.
Well, I say tunes, but it was really a white
noise machine.
He didn't care for music, it was a bit too
much excitement.
He was just getting into the flow of his work,
when there was a knock at his office door.
"Excuse me, sir?"
A Research Assistant was standing at the door,
pale and anxious, a clipboard in his hands.
"They're requesting your help with an emergency
down the hall."
"What is it?"
Dr. Gears asked.
"They didn't really say, just something about
Dr. Bright and chainsaws?"
The assistant stammered.
Dr. Gears sighed and stood up from his desk.
"I'll be right there."
There wouldn't be anyone keeping an eye on
SCP-914, but at this point, the experimentation
process basically ran itself.
Everything would be fine if Dr. Gears stepped
away for a little while...wouldn't it?
Meanwhile, across the Site, a very enterprising
mask became keenly aware of an opportunity
presenting itself.
It had been lying in wait, meticulously planning
and plotting for days,
and now, there was an opening it could take
advantage of.
You see, months ago, the mask had managed
to finagle itself a host, a researcher who
had just been working with SCP-914.
When the Mask's consciousness took over the
man's, and it got an up close and personal
look at all of his thoughts as they snuffed
out one by one,
it learned all about the marvelous, miraculous
Clockworks.
The machine capable of transforming anything
into a better version of itself.
The Mask had fantasized, obsessed about getting
to SCP-914, of using it to mold itself, to
change into something greater and more powerful.
Then, perhaps, it could escape this place
and return to its former freedom and glory.
Of course, it would have to select the correct
setting.
One wrong choice, and the whole plan could
amount to nothing.
On Rough, the Mask would likely be destroyed,
reduced to a pile of ceramic dust or perhaps
even a ball of unmolded clay
alongside some of the black slime always oozing
from its eyes and mouth.
On Coarse, it would likely be transformed
into a slab of plan porcelain, uncarved and
unpainted.
On 1:1, the Mask would likely be swapped out
with another anomalous object, some other
enterprising mask
or perhaps a haunted Victorian doll or some
other malicious inanimate thing.
And what use would that be?
No, that wouldn't do at all.
Fine could be promising, and would likely
prevent the Mask from degrading any future
hosts it decided to take...but why stop there?
Why should it limit itself to simply Fine,
when Very Fine was right there and looking
oh so promising?
It decided, if it could get to SCP-914, it
would find a way to transform itself using
the Very Fine setting.
And then, its enemies, this pathetic Foundation,
the entire world...would fall to their knees.
It had been watching patiently, like a snake
coiled and ready to snap up its prey, spreading
its psychic tendrils as far as they could
go,
and anticipating the moment that someone left
SCP-914 unattended.
Now, the moment had arrived.
Of course, the Mask would need help.
It didn't have a way to reach the Clockworks
on its own.
So, it had been wrapping its influence around
the guard stationed just outside its door,
dripping thoughts into his head, whispering
darkness into his ear at every chance it got.
Chipping away at his will, bit by bit, until
the man was little more than a puppet with
the Possessive Mask tugging at his strings.
The Mask gave a mental yank on one of those
strings, calling the man in its thrall into
the room.
He knocked out his fellow guard with the butt
of his gun, first.
At this point, his mind was so pliable that
he would do anything to please the Mask.
Next, the man entered the containment chamber,
a glassy, vacant look in his eyes.
He unlocked the glass case and reached inside,
lifting the mask out, and bringing it one
step closer to absolute freedom.
He tucked the mask inside of his uniform,
hiding it from any prying eyes, and began
to walk steadily toward SCP-914's room.
All the while, the Mask whispered silent encouragements
into the man's weakened mind, promising him
power and success beyond his wildest dreams,
if only he would help it achieve this goal.
Of course, the mask was planning to kill the
man as soon as his task was done, but he didn't
need to know that yet.
Every step brought the Mask closer to victory,
and it was practically vibrating with the
delicious anticipation of it all.
Soon, so soon.
They reached the containment room, the Clockworks
just beyond the door.
The guard carried the Mask into the room,
placed the Mask inside of the Intake Booth,
closed it, and approached the Control Panel.
In accordance with the Mask's psychic instructions,
he selected "Very Fine," and turned the machine
on.
The cogs and gears inside whirred to life,
the engine sputtered, metal clanked and pipes
exhaled hissing bursts of energy.
The Output chamber opened, and through the
curtain of steam, SCP-035 stepped in its new
and improved form.
That's right, stepped.
First one long, sinewy leg, leathery, shiny,
and black as the night, extended into view.Another
leg followed, and along with it came a torso,
a pair of arms, a slender neck, and the familiar
face of the Mask, stark white against the
darkness of its new body.
The feet ended in little points, as if the
figure was wearing boots, but there was no
visible clothing.
It was all one thing, angular and strange,
with long, long fingers tipped with curved
claws.
The mask let out a wicked cackle, throwing
back its head in triumph.
"Excellent..it's even better than I imagined."
The Mask turned to the guard that had helped
it escape.
"Thank you for your service.
Now, I have one last favor to ask you..."
It was time for the Mask to test its powers,
to see how the Clockworks had strengthened
what was already there.
What more was it capable of, in this enhanced
state.
"I want you to go to the cafeteria, walk into
the kitchen, and climb into the oven, would
you?
Make sure you turn it on nice and hot first."
It waited for a few seconds, before the man
nodded solemnly, turned, and left the room,
heading off in the direction of the cafeteria.
It listened as the moments passed, and the
sound of horrified, shocked screams rang out,
and it knew that the man had followed its
instructions exactly.
At the Mask's orders, he had cooked himself
for lunch.
The Mask clapped its hands together, cackling
again.
"Wonderful!
Oh, wonderful.
Now that's taken care of...what shall I try
next?"
If the Mask had eyebrows, they would have
been arched in a truly devilish expression.
First, it wanted to test its abilities on
a truly formidable opponent, someone worthy
of the Mask's time and attention.
Casually as you please, it strode over to
one particular containment chamber, to see
about an unkillable reptile.
As it walked, several guards took notice,
pointing their weapons at the Mask and ordering
it to stand down.
Each time, it chuckled, and with a wave of
its hand, the barrels of their guns warped
and twisted into little metal bows, completely
useless.
It snapped its clawed fingers, and the guards
fell to the ground in an unconscious heap.
"Can't have you sounding the alarm yet, the
fun is only just beginning!"
The Mask remarked, though it knew the guards
couldn't hear it.
It kicked open the door to SCP-682's containment
room with a jaunty greeting.
"Hello, you scaly fool!
I've come to pay you a visit!"
The reptile did not respond, incapacitated
by its hydrochloric acid bath.
That just wouldn't do.
The Mask concentrated, and the steel chamber
broke apart, acid spilling everywhere, hissing
as it splashed onto any available surface.
SCP-682 lifted its head, twitching its tail,
and took in the sight of the new and improved
Mask.
"What do you think?"
The Mask posed for the creature, laughing
again.
It seemed it couldn't stop laughing lately,
its expression fixed into a permanent gleeful
smile.
It couldn't help it, freedom and power just
felt so good.
"Disssgussssting."
SCP-682 remarked, unimpressed with this display.
It lunged at the Mask, preparing to attack,
but the Mask held up a hand to stop it.
"Not so fast."
SCP-682 suddenly froze in place, eyes rolling
wildly as it tried desperately, in vain, to
move.
"Let's see, what should I do with you..."
The Mask was itching to test out its reality-warping
abilities.
It had the feeling that there was very little
it couldn't do in this state, and wanted to
see just how far its power could go.
But what would be suitable punishment, what
could be the cruelest possible thing to do
to such a creature?
The Mask could simply try to kill it, to finally
snuff out the endless, miserable life…
but that would be a release.
That would be far too easy.
Aha!
A lightbulb went off in the Mask's twisted
mind.
"Perfect."
It waved its hand, releasing SCP-682 from
its paralysis,
but as the massive lizard snapped its jaws
and moved to take a bite out of the Mask,
it lost its balance, falling to the ground.
Its legs had begun to shrink, rapidly, knocking
its center of gravity askew.
Soon, the rest of its body began to follow,
getting smaller and smaller at an unbelievable
pace,
until finally, where there had once stood
a massive, impossible, prehistoric beast,
was something resembling a baby alligator.
A little tiny tail, thrashing about, short
stubby legs, bulbous eyes, and a mouth full
of sharp, but adorable non-threatening, teeth.
When the shrunken SCP-682 spoke, its voice
was high-pitched and squeaky.
"Disgussssting!"
It roared.
"Yes.
You are."
The Mask turned and left, thoroughly pleased
with its work, and shut the door behind it.
Now, what other fellow anomalies could the
Mask exercise its absolute superiority over?
It pondered other supposedly "dangerous" and
"deadly" entities that it had heard about
over its time in Foundation custody.
It all seemed so...laughable now.
There was only one true danger within these
walls, and it was the Mask.
Oh, what about that abominable sculpture?
The ugly thing with a penchant for snapping
necks, but only when a person wasn't looking
at it.
The absolute coward.
Cowards didn't deserve to live, the Mask decided,
and it made its way over toward SCP-173's
containment room.
Inside, there were several D-Class staring
at the statue with wide, unblinking eyes,
each person terrified of being the one to
let their guard down and lose their life in
the process.
\
None of them would die today, however.
At least...not at the hands of the statue.
As the D-Class in the cell watched, never
once taking their eyes off of SCP-173, the
statue's head began to twist and rotate, the
sound of cracking snow and creaking metal
reverberating through the room.
The Mask used its telekinetic abilities to
rend the statue's head from its neck, relishing
the irony of breaking the thing's neck just
as it had done to so many others.
It wasn't about justice, of course, the Mask
had no taste for such insipid and human things,
it just found the whole image quite funny.
the entire thing began to crumble apart
like a sandcastle beneath an ocean wave,
disintegrating until all that was left was
a pile of pebbles and dust.
Just like that, SCP-173 was no more.
As for the D-Class in the cell, well, the
Mask could use some servants.
"You all, come with me," The Mask ordered,
flexing its iron will and quickly capturing
the weak, fear-addled minds of the D-Class
personnel before it.
They fell in line, shuffling out the door
and following the Mask with the same blank
expressions as the guard before.
Whatever was left of their personalities after
so much time being used and abused by the
Foundation, it was gone now, replaced only
with the will of the mighty Mask.
As the Mask continued its victory tour of
the Foundation, now with four mindless servants
in tow, it passed the staff break room.
Through the window, it spotted one Dr. Bright,
the telltale amulet around his neck, microwaving
some leftover pizza.
The Mask had always found Dr. Bright distasteful,
with his self-aggrandizing pranks and general
dedication to chaos with no grand vision behind
it,
no meaningful agenda.
It was pitiful.
It was deeply ugly.
And now, the Mask had a chance to put an end
to the immortal Doctor's antics once and for
all.
It opened the door, greeting Dr. Bright with
that frozen grin.
"Oh, Doctor..."
Dr. Bright's eyes widened, and he didn't even
hear the microwave behind him ding, signaling
that his pizza was ready.
He was too distracted by the horrifying sight
before him.
But as he opened his mouth to scream, to quip,
to call for help, the Mask reached out and
ripped the amulet from his neck.
The host body fell limply to the ground, and
the Mask looked down at the amulet, glinting
in the light, that held Dr. Bright's consciousness
inside.
It stared at the amulet with a flinty gaze,
and under its empty stare, the metal began
to rust, to degrade, and to melt into an unrecognizable
slurry.
The Mask let it drip onto the floor, then,
when all that was Dr. Bright had melted away,
it wiped its hand off with a napkin, and ground
the wet puddle on the ground with its heel.
"Goodbye, Doctor."
The Mask hissed.
"Now, what's next!"
But as the Mask turned to walk down the hall,
it came face to face with a disapproving face.
SCP-343 had manifested directly in front of
the Mask, and he clearly had learned of the
Mask's behavior so far that day.
"You've been busy," 343 remarked.
"Yes, very busy.
Lots to do, you see," The Mask chuckled smugly.
"You understand why I can't allow this to
continue?"
343's expression remained stern but calm.
"You believe you can stop me?"
The Mask tilted its head to the side.
"Of course, I can."
SCP-343 sighed.
"But you could stop on your own, if you would
rather.
I'd prefer to avoid an unnecessary conflict."
The Mask giggled uncontrollably at this.
"I'm going to rend the flesh from your bones,"
It simply said.
"I thought you might say something like that.
I'm going to have to take your body.
I'm sorry."
SCP-343 prepared to teleport the Mask's new
body to another location, separating them
and reducing the Mask to its original, more
manageable state.
But before he could, there was suddenly darkness
in the room, every light blinking out all
at once.
The hall was plunged into shadow, but this
was no ordinary darkness.
This darkness was inky, thick, choking like
smoke clinging to the inside of your throat.
Then, just as suddenly as it appeared, the
darkness dissipated.
But SCP-343 was gone.
He hadn't teleported himself to somewhere
else, he hadn't walked through the wall to
get away from the Mask.
He was truly gone.
The Mask couldn't be certain exactly what
it had done to SCP-343, but it knew that the
enemy had been truly eradicated.
In fact, it was fairly certain he had been
erased from reality entirely.
The Mask made one final lap around the Foundation
Containment Site, bidding farewell to every
anomaly it passed.
Some it transformed, like it had done to SCP-682.
Taking inspiration from its bird-like face,
the Mask turned the Plague Doctor into a crow.
Others it simply executed, such as the poor
SCP-096, whose screams and shrieks had always
irritated the Mask.
Of course, Foundation staff began to notice
what was happening, and they tried to defeat
the Mask.
They shot at it with their puny weapons, they
sounded their useless alarms, and they called
for their laughable backup.
But none of it mattered, not in the face of
the Mask.
Guns melted in guards' hands, alarms went
silent at nothing more than a glance, and
more and more mindless slaves joined the Mask's
army.
It didn't want too many, that would just be
difficult to keep track of.
But an even dozen seemed like the perfect
number.
With this miniature army in tow, the Mask
finally made its way to its final destination:
The Exit.
It had been waiting for this moment, dreaming
of it, since it was first imprisoned so long
ago.
As it stepped out into the sun, the Mask realized
that, though it didn't have nostrils,
it could smell the breeze, the scent of wildflowers
and grass.
What a beautiful place to mold in the Mask's
image of an ideal world.
The world was its oyster, and The Mask longed
to swallow it whole.
The current whereabouts of The Possessive
Mask are unknown.
The Foundation is doing its best to locate
the Mask,
and determine new effective measures for bringing
it down and re-containing it as soon as possible.
The escape of the Mask is being considered
a possible XK-Class End of the World Scenario,if
it cannot be stopped.
The best and brightest minds at the Foundation
are working on it,
aside from Dr. Bright of course, may he rest
in peace.
But right now, there is very little anyone
can do.
So, if you see a strange dark figure in a
white mask walking down your street, do yourself
a favor and run the other way, before it's
too late.
Now go check out “Could SCP-682 be Contained
in the Backrooms?”
and “SCP-096 VS Siren Head” for more terrifying
anomalous hypotheticals!